welcome back to brain review my name is
Caleb Dendy and today I'm going to be
taking you through another game from the
Tata Steel masters tournament that has
been going on recently this is a game
between the 16 year-old Iranian Alireza
Perugia and Vladislav Artemyev from
Russia now from your has been on a bit
of a hot streak lately he's been
performing very very well in these super
tournaments and that was no different
for the start of this Tata Steel of
masters and here we see he managed to
actually win this game against Artemyev
and we had this happen in a caro-kann
and personally I'm devastated Karel Khan
one of my favorite openings always hurts
to see it get beaten but alligaroos el
Reza did very very accurately and very
professionally it was very impressive to
see so we see a 5 Bishop f5 h4 h5 and
then c4 and this is not the most topical
line actually these days after h4 h5 a
lot of white players have been trying to
do Bishop d3 and after takes takes c6
Bishop g5 and this is how players with
the white pieces have been playing for
an advantage in this advanced variation
quite often but this was not Ali razors
choice he chose c4 trying to break in
the center very early on and give blacks
and concrete problems black responds
with a 6 supporting d5 see Knight c3 97
9 GE 2 not coming to f3 but rather to e
to the idea of possibly harassing this
Bishop in the future in the game black
plays 97 obviously in the caro-kann a
very common break is to play c5 but due
to the way the black is played in the
opening this pawn break is actually not
going to be as good here we had to put
this night on e7 2 ports to support our
C pawn so now after c5 this pawn can
actually be captured this can be rather
difficult for white to deal with
especially with the threat of a knight
coming into this d6 square
so rather than see five black supports
his pawns from behind a little bit more
with 97 white continues with Knight g3
like I said harassing this Bishop Bishop
drops back to g6 this Bishop does come
out to this g5 Square we see Queen b6
now is the main move and now le Reza
chooses a bit of a side line the most
common move here by far is Queen d2
simply defending this beep on but white
chooses this move rook c1 and here you
might think that black can simply
capture this pawn on b2 and you might be
correct but White's simply going to
develop very naturally with Bishop d3
and after takes takes your queen does
start to feel a little bit out of place
on this B 2 Square and they're going to
have to contend with an eventual rook b1
trying to regain this pawn on b7 this
can be quite dangerous for blacks to go
and start grabbing these Queen side
pawns well the king is still stuck in
the center like this so instead black
chose a more conservative approach
rather than take this b2 pawn he simply
captures on c4 and now White has given
up control over this d5 square and black
will look to use that to his advantage
in this game
Bishop takes c4 as White's choice and
now black really started to to go astray
here and once black started making
inaccuracies Alireza
really didn't take his foot off the gas
and he really punished black quite
effectively in the game black played
Knight f5 which is a very understandable
move it aims to trade off pieces
immediately and try and reach more of an
endgame type position we're having this
King stuck in the center isn't gonna be
such a big deal and while this is
commendable there are some concrete
problems with it which we will see
something black might have considered
instead is to play Queen side castles
either immediately or after move like
Queen b4 which does clear this space for
the night if need be we can imagine
Queen before something like Bishop b3
and now after Queen side castles we're
putting a lot of pressure on this D pawn
as well as this epon kind of indirectly
using this pin against the Queen and
this is pretty difficult for white to
deal with actually and the main lines
usually go King side castles and white
actually does give up this pawn for
compensation and you can see kind of a
stark difference between these types of
lines and what happens in the game
because in these lines white center kind
of collapses and we'll see that
something very different happens in the
game so once again would have liked to
see something along the lines of Queen
side castles or maybe queen be four
followed by Queen side castles instead
though Knight f5 was blacks choice
trying to trade off pieces in response
ali reza simply castles you can't really
take this pawn on d4 because you run
into problems with a very very nasty
move Knight b5 and this is something you
really do hate to see if this Knight
were to be captured first of all simply
Bishop takes and white is going to
regain this piece on d7 and also black
is looking a little bit a little bit
checkmated the most forcing line goes a6
between d4 94 Bishop d7 King B 7 and
after rook d1 this piece is going to be
regained and likely these complications
are something black didn't really
account for why it's simply ignoring the
threat to the d4 pawn and continuing I
do want to briefly mention Knight b5 you
might be tempted to ignore this but that
fails to checkmate it's always got to be
careful so this pawn is actually
uncapturable which is really unfortunate
for black here but instead black offers
more trades of pieces and in this case
why actually does accept but black has
given up something in order to trade off
these pieces sking is now locked in the
center queenside castles no longer legal
King side castles also illegal
due to the king having moved and this is
going to cause black some problems Queen
d2 must plate finally keeping an eye on
this pawn queen D it was black's choice
perhaps not the best but it's really
difficult to find moves
he is of course making this threat here
and Alireza responds to this threat
quite effectively with 91 the point
being if you want to take this now I'll
have a check to step out of this
annoying pin and then I can capture your
knight Knight b6 was black's choice
trying to make use of this d5 square but
now Ali Reza once again ignores the
threat plays the ambitious Knight e3 now
if you were to capture this I have moves
like Queen B for again it also moves
like Knight takes f5 that you're going
to have to contend with King f8 is
blacks choice trying to get the King to
safety but after Knight f5 pawn takes e5
once again we'd like to take off this
bishop but in this case there's Queen
before check and we can save the night
before recapturing so the bishop gets to
live we have to capture back on f5 and
now the end is is really near you see
the power of white center as well as the
power of the white Bishop over the the
Black Knight here black does pick up
this pawn but this pawn is pretty
irrelevant to the game actually simply
rook e1 supports the center even further
and now after rook h6 what uses the
center to open up the black King and the
end is near with this file opening this
diagonal opening in this diagonal
already looking at this King and
checkmate is approaching we see pawn
takes Bishop takes this R it comes to
eat eight and this Bishop collects this
f5 pawn because why not we see a trade
of rooks black tries to come back to
defend his King with Queen d8 but now
after Queen d3 a nice move king f7 and
Queen f3
White is rerouting around this black
King and there's simply no shelter
anywhere on the board for this King the
Queen comes to f6 once again trying to
defends now Queen b3 check King f8 Queen
a3 check Queen D 6 and now Queen III and
after some fancy footwork with the queen
ali reza is
coming through on the e-file Queen d8
was blacks choice simply Queenie for ali
reza is a no rush to checkmate the King
because the King isn't going anywhere
Queenie for starts making these types of
threats on the king after Bishop g6
brick f6 is blacks choice he continues
with Bishop g6 anyways threatening a
checkmate King d8 with the idea of rook
f8 to block but now Queen h4 Queen d5
rook e8 check rook f8 now after Queen e7
it's very apparent that the black king
is not going to survive I keep saying
this but it was never really in doubt
the king with no shelter on the board
and this night being in useless peace
was was doomed from the start
97 Bishop C - Ali Reza's choice to
really highlight the unfortunate
placement of blacks pieces Queen takes
d4 is what black tried and now rook f8 9
f8 Bishop b3 and the King can't stay
tethered to the knight and ali reza wins
a piece and goes on to win this game
which we'll check out very very quickly
of course this is just an extra bishop
queen bee - was played ship GA check
King age 6 weena for g5 Queen d6 King g7
Bishop b3 its King once again very very
lacking in shelter Queen e1 check and
black does trade the Queen's to avoid
getting checkmated but of course this is
a hopeless endgame
down a full-piece white collects the
kingside pawns uses the bishop to stop
black's Queen side and then advances
this pawn to victory and after g6 c 3 in
Bishop d1 black threw in the towel and
resigned here
White's simply queening first so once
again a very impressive game from
Perugia here ripping open the center and
the King using his central majority and
black playing a little bit slightly
slightly odd and so it's a good reminder
not to focus simply on trading pieces
but to
your pieces into the game and find
counterplay thank you for joining me
this week on game review and I will see
you in the next episode